hören sie auf
dann fängt jetzt die neue folge an und
damit aber auch eine neue eine neue
frage was nehmen wir einmal ich nehme
mal punk achterbahn erhaltet ihr volk
erstmals das punk ist nein
kristen ist ein original so ist das von
youtube aus ein original channel das
heißt youtube sponsor den channel
angeblich mit einer million angeblich
sollte es aber doch ein bisschen weniger
sein man könnte aber mal ich denke mal
so 800.000 euro oder sowas bestimmt drin
und damit sponsort youtube den kanal
dass der hoch qualitativen content vital
und er wird geleitet von waikiki also
von den leuten und mit dabei sind auch e
crime und ein chor oder wieder heiß
nature place gleich ein kokon das was
anderes heute jedenfalls irgendwas und
auch ein michael rinn
was haltet ihr davon also erstmal kippe
weil wir haben also in den sinn kommen
also youtube generell muss ich sagen hat
sich also wie so ein generell übelsten
tun gehabt muss sagen in den letzten
paar jahren und es ist ja praktisch und
wie das zweite fernsehen ich meinen
verein da nächstes jahr auch so dass man
sich die sender spezielle wenn ein
programm gut ist wird das zu sagen öfter
ausländischen rasern frage wo bist du
luca bei mir zu hause hast du steine für
mich eine sage ich jetzt buchung holz
steine buchen wollte buchenholz auf dort
auf englisch und man dass das weiße holz
ein
das unerwartet dass ich glaub ich jeder
ist eins davon birke 1 nach einer die
halle
ihr wartet so viel kann ich gegeben hier
das meer habe ich nicht
wir haben doch bestellten guttenberg
hatte vielleicht habe ich noch einmal
nachhaltig wollt ihr noch nicht gemacht
nein habe ich nicht
ich könnte ja wenn ich echt ok kerken
habt ihr erde noch nie war das war das
falsche heute ich musste gerade hardcore
erde zusammen fahren und erde habe ich
für dich durch die reha sich bringen
fast den ganzen berg ist noch da ich kam
ja alles links ab ach so erde wo für
draußen die erde hierfür überall wo er
das alles nicht eben ist
was die neuen steine schön für mich
ja ich hab ganz viel ich glaub ich auch
stein die erde hat einfach hin gebaut
ich habe ganz viele geben ich hab meine
rache nicht ich habe sie zu bleiben
reicht nicht mal ein jahr alt als er ist
ich habe noch etwas zu essen ich warum
männer töten lassen töten nein macht
nicht mal richtig verdient hält man
jetzt mal wenn ich gegen mein freund das
ist sehr nett aber ist es gegeben für
werkzeuge
ich weiß ich bin noch am baum aber du
hast eigentlich werkzeugen die schaufel
ist jetzt gerade auf hör auf ich habe
jetzt wieder volles leben mein freund
und ich dich allerdings raus geholt
vielleicht es nicht merkt stand 17 level
hat kann das echt unfair
hören sie auf ich habe ihn ja nicht mal
geschlagen ich laufe ihm hinterher
ich habe kein schwert in der hand
er wollte ich du hast dich spitzhacke
ich wollte steiner abbauen und ich hab
mir ich habe volles leben und ich hab
mich schwert aus diamant als er ein
schwert und ich hab ein bisschen rüstung
du du hast so schwer dass diamanten
kämpfer raus aus meinem haus raus aus
meinem markus randale bösen wasser das
thema eigentlich für diese feier war was
das konzert wird und da war ich gerade
dabei zu erklären dann manchmal das
zweite fernsehen ist und ich meine wenn
ein programm
häufig kommt beispielsweise the big bang
theory sind richtig toll
dann wird das auch häufig ausgestrahlt
das ist für mich eigentlich wie sponsern
deswegen finde ich das eigentlich in
ordnung ich weiß aber nicht was da kann
also liefert die machen montags immer
seinen spot so ein herr würde die woche
montags aber seine sketche also ein
bearbeitetes video wahrscheinlich
dienstags machen die ich mach doch nicht
weiter
dienstags machen sie hinter den kulissen
also was so in der wg da abgeht als sie
erwarten eine wohnung mittwochs machen
die
das machen sie noch mal mittwochs der
wechsel ist gerade so das ist ja was
wird noch entschieden
ich glaube ich wusste irgendwann machen
irgendwas mit einer dass sie nicht
trafen umfragen man er gerne unsere
marge richtig komisch das machen jedoch
auch schon so oft im normaler genauer
das meine ich dass es halt allgemein an
sich ist das toll dass es im kanal von
mehreren youtube an das gibt es jetzt
noch nicht so wirklich von mehreren
großen youtube allerdings von den ganzen
sachen diese da geplant haben ist das
nichts neues
ja deswegen das habe ich nicht gewusst
dass mir noch irgendwie qualitativ
hochwertiger noch gemacht werden habe
das einzige was wohl die einzigen
konkurrenten machen anfängt geholt das
ist das ziel
vielleicht weil das einzige
professionelle da für mich ist in ton
auto und alles relativ schnell
aufgefahren hat hoher youtube qualität
ich finde das habe ich jetzt auch für
diese folgen hier drin
das ist so süß das ist so zuckersüß da
geht dann richtig das herz auf ich finds
auch cool schreien immer in ihrem tempo
her kennt ihr das
und ihr schreibt er fast nie woher ein
manche irgendwo ein kinofilm soll sei
nicht mit den angeschaut den trailer
davon
da hab ich aber nicht davon ich habe es
ihr neu gelesen das ist echt sehr gut
ankommt das intro also alle schreiber ja
wie bei so einer kinderserie wirklich
und so ist es wirklich nötig sagt den
laufpass folgen
er welche welchen materialien kann man
so für säulen benutzen die man so unten
im keller hat du kannst enstone nehmen
aber den musst du noch einmal nochmal
kräften an veränderte seine formen mit
der sohn so ein break förmiger center
und ist eigentlich ganz cool bin ich zu
blöd in meinem inventar glasscheiben zu
finden
hier warte ich muss man noch 19 us cent
ich mache sondern beta let's play von
von einer alten beta version und
deswegen vergeht sich immer dass ich ja
hier sprinten kann es ganz blöd das ist
luxus ist echt blöd der mann man merkt
schon wie viele vorteile man hier
vorteile vorteile man hier hat bevor
in 1 54 auch am posten machen also
eigentlich will ich dafür dass ihr viele
ist dass wir die xp einsetzen haben
überhaupt diamanten schon jene oder elf
vor allem nicht die wahren renner im
silbersee aber wir haben nur übels viel
ich habe zb 46 eisen und acht airbags
oder ex aber gar keinen
wir müssen unbedingt damit wir uns in
chongqing können wir einen allgemeinen
john cale machen den dann alle wieder
bei denen alle benutzen und auch einen
brand oder so obwohl ich mir noch nicht
mit brown ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel
aus kenne ich auch nicht ich weiß nur
dass sie dafür müssen auf jeden fall ja
weil wir diese komische dinge drin dafür
dass ihr minecraft backhaus
zweckentfremden als born und es wird das
altstadthaus benutzen und auch sowas
rheinpark
das muss dann schon mal ein bisschen
schöner werden naja aber dass wir das
man also damit ausbauen
ok oder lassen wir das so als als ruine
steht bei münchen ist auf jeden fall
hefti musste ein bisschen mit anpacken
dass zumindest der nächste gast nicht
dein schicksal wieder erleiden muss vor
allem das plus für den allein schon der
zaun heißt es doch überhaupt nicht
verdient die sechs hatte verdient das
plus weil sie gern wo das herkommt ich
bewerte ich jetzt mal selbst
die bewertung gefällt mir nicht einfach
meine eigene in der schule auf den etwas
an deiner meinung punkt soll noch gar
nicht gesagt meine und auch wenn sie
allen die in die skelettierte mich vor
fünf schneiden auch wenn jetzt alle
wieder die kontrolle schreibt mir bist
krank wenn noch so kälte und sohn er
also nicht wundern wenn ich euch da mal
wieder geschmackvoll ins ohr wusste aber
meine meinung zu punkt ist eigentlich
das eigentlich jetzt erst mal sehr gut
dass youtube halt so geld in diese in da
rein steckt professionelleren content zu
machen aber dann finde ich es doch
relativ enttäuschend was sie machen bis
jetzt ich meine was das naschen draußen
mein erstes richtiges video und dann all
dieses also zum zeitpunkt dieser
aufnahmen meine freunde und dann haben
sie irgendwie so ein blog wo sie einmal
durch die wohnung rennen und sich
gegenseitig schellen geben wenn sie
fragen nicht beantworten
es ist alles ganz lustig wenn man sich
diese allgemeine diesen allgemeinen
youtube humor an damit anfreunden kann
es ist nicht schlecht aber es ist halt
nichts besonderes ich finde sich an als
den usa geborene channel auch welt
gesponsert sind zum beispiel source
fährt das von philipp frank oz team und
das ist halt sehr professionell news so
aufbereitet aber im youtube-stream was
neues also und sehr professionell und da
die finde ich richtig geil aber damals
gar nicht es gibt auch allgemein
amerikanische kanäle die allgemeinen
jetzt schon besser sind obwohl sie nicht
diese original channel sind
das soll heute schon besser sind als das
was hier die deutschen da machen und es
gibt ja auch so also ich finde allgemein
das wieder deutlich noch mehr
investieren kann wenn sie wirklich so
viel geld kriegen dann denke ich könnte
da schon bisher eine million ist echt
nicht viel im infusion der
videoprojektion ja ja aber ich meine die
verdienen ja durch die ganze video ist
auch noch was
naja das auch aber es ist auch nicht wie
jetzt nach einem video die welt ist das
ehrlich die channel sollen langfristig
sollen hier von den werbeeinnahmen leben
das hat die ganzen channel 20 machen ja
auch noch geld und die stecken
mittlerweile die wir alle zusammen das
heißt das geld das wir durch sich
verdient durch
bis ich selber dass das fließt alles ja
da rein die leben als quasi zusammen
die waikiki nicht nur crime dieser tools
und diese schauspielerin nicht auch noch
mit dabei die produzenten sozusagen oder
auch nur vielleicht auch noch diese
infill von denen also ich war aber ich
möchte jetzt auch kein falschaussagen
tätig aber an sich so leben die da
zusammen hatte die hat die darsteller
halt davon sind natürlich noch die
brisanz des ganzen erhöhen oder minen
werden tag und nacht ein bisschen
geschnitten wo ich meine meine kisten
hier hinein
ich habe es so ähnlich meine
ausgefertigt so andreas und kirsten raum
gemacht im keller
naja aber sicher schon im keller also
ich persönlich finde kellerduell
vielleicht magst du die werbe von
kellern medium ich weiß trotzdem keller
hierhin was ist die perfekte höhe für
diamanten 12 ja also zwischen zwölf und
zwanzig oder soll man es kaum ein
unterschied
roger moore lässt sich einfach
irgendeiner höhle zu gehen die ungefähr
auf der höhe ist er bisher zu einer
höhle nenne ich macht astrid mining
strip meinung hast du aber du bist auf
jeden fall am ihnen gerade schon und so
sollte ein optimist du ja gleich
glücklich ich bin jetzt zwölf jeden
moment so genau jetzt
alt und jung richtig laut lover immer
noch beim einem zaun sich klicken
einfach nicht fertig wird aber richtig
kaliber wie viel eisen fuß zu fassen
schönborn und keine eindringlinge
reinkommen nicht sind eigentlich schon
wie einer neuen folge nämlich schon
wieder in einer voll neuen folge seht
seht ihr wenn wir sehen ob wir schon
wieder neuen folge sind auf jeden fall
sind wir in einer neuen folge super
übergeleiteten alles klar
ob sie wirklich richtig steht seht ihr
wenn das licht angeht
ok solchen euro von 1 2 oder 3
dass ich mich mit meinen geschwistern
mit bennett und noch anderen wie viele
geschwister denn genug genug wie bisher
als beendet aber da haben wir immer mit
gerade mal 23
ja aber später noch bei schlag den raab
mitgemacht wenn ratespielen rede spaß
ganz richtig anspruchsvoll schlag den
raab musste mich geschlagen und junge du
so ein riesen loch ist das alter hast du
alles wieder auf eines war ich nicht du
hast mich drauf geschockt auf die
treasure play du hast ja auch hingesetzt
ja aber nein die hast du ihn gesetzt
lasst mich in ruhe was mir scheiß egal
wie viele level du hast alter lass mich
in ruhe
nein das ist mir scheißegal wie level du
hast alter wenn du weder der denen ich
habe nein ich habe mir selber schon zwei
täter gemacht und wollte sie aber nicht
hinsetzen